let me ask you guys you having a little
date night out tonight is it feel good
to get out of the house where who is do
his babysitting what's going on well we
put the boys down so their bedtime was
perfect timing for us to get here to
this party yeah we could watch the nest
you know we have them on the nest you
have a climb up monitor them I certainly
don't but I love it there never you're
gonna keep that nest on until they're 18
I think we're getting working on getting
a service we need to get it figured out
so you watch them on the nest you have a
little date night out like how much do
you guys party uh nights like this the
camera pick up the real camera minimizes
eyelashes so I have to maximize just
like you're doing with your shirt is the
first anyone's mentioned it these out
yourself do you approve how do we choose
two different questions I have a whole
method but do you approve do you approve
is the question I read something very
distressing is it true that you almost
weren't in the entire Jurassic Park
series your character was almost written
out what I felt I tell that amusing
anecdote when I first met mr. Spielberg
speaking of which yeah he said you know
there's a move afoot I'm using the word
irregular whereby you know that you're
the screenplay won't include your
character from the book so we're meeting
you know when we schedule this meeting
it was still in now it may be out I was
like should I come to your senses I
didn't say that but words to that effect
so many in moments this is unbelievable
well we get more will we see you in
another Jurassic Park movie should it
happen it probably will
no I don't know I know fortune teller
but I see many things in your future
Zima you kind of wear a fortune teller
in this well I guess the collector
wasn't I was no but I was prescient I
was prescient and I was wise I was
saying to Charlie tonight we were
looking at a sticker book I mean doing
the stickers we finished up a cigarette
and I would whisper in his ear whereas
he picked which sticker to pick I would
say choose wisely my son he's three but
he got a big kick out of it watching him
being hilarious death personality traits
that Jeff has it's amazing I gave a
sliver of my cough drop once and he
almost cried was too much for him but
when I have something like this I say
smell my breath
you know and then he said many said
smell my breath he goes it's the
sweetest thing to feel his little breath
last question for you your co-star in
the Jurassic Park moves Laura Dern just
killing it I mean big little lies
nominated again tonight how proud are
you and do you talk to her often now yep
you know I saw her yeah I love her and
very proud and I saw her at the at the
Calvin Klein slash RAF Simmons Fashion
Show in Fashion Week in New York a few
nights ago yeah
Hillary beautiful beautiful family a
beautiful Sun she's fantastic
you know and we'll get her in another
Jurassic Park movie I'll bet if I could
see the future correctly
[Music]
[Applause]